hello hey hey Lakewood
Police Megan
Megan
hey hey Megan Meg
Meg Megan hey
hey Megan
Megan hey Megan look at me look at
me Megan Megan look at me look at me I'm
officer Cooper what's going on
Megan Megan Megan stay with me what's
going on right now you're passed out in
the Taco Bell driver what's going on NOP
turn the car off turn the car turn the
Megan turn the car off turn the car
off press the button and turn the no
press don't no press the button to turn
the car
off what's going on
tonight um
I'm sorry they
[Music]
didn't I planned on us getting the home
they didn't say it's
safe I don't understand a little bit of
any part of what you just
said so we got a call the you're passed
out in the drive through right now and
so I come here and I see you slumped
over at the wheel yeah this is the
second time got called second time yes
the first time you weren't here so the
second time when I got here I the second
time I called the first time you called
the first time on yourself yeah I
said my guys yeah oh now I'm being
called okay I think you're confused
what's going on I'm
sorry have you been drinking at all
tonight no are you sure 100% so what
have you been doing tonight then I was
making sure everybody's okay who's who's
everybody no no don't turn the car on
leave it
off what were you doing what's what's
been going on tonight CU this is like I
said the second time we've been called
to you pass down the drive-thru but this
time we actually found you and when I
pulled up you were slumped over
completely passed
out so what's explain to me what's going
out
where is my boyfriend I don't know he's
not here yeah he's not
here do you have a driver's license on
you
yeah
[Music]
sorry Megan do you have your insurance
with you
I
insurance I'm
[Music]
sorry what are you drinking
tonight mag what were you drinking
tonight um um I don't drink very much no
no can you do me a favor yes you know
your alphabet yeah okay can you state it
don't sing it just state it highspeed
chases we got unruly suspects I will
kill that mothers me no do it stay in
the I like it Kink dramatic DUI I'm a
pass she trying to do and shocking body
cam footage hey get on the go get on the
law and crime presents body cam the
place for real raw and wild police
videos you should have seen it it was
good it's on body camera I'll show it to
you catch the action and subscribe to
our new YouTube channel
[Music]
now like the alphabet yes the
alphabet like a b c d e f g h i j k l m
n o
p okay keep go
QRS
TV WX y n z okay can can I see the
insurance yeah okay where were you at
tonight um we were at a friend's house
actually okay what were you guys doing
at that friend's
house um we hanging out what the
hell seriously I'm
sorry what okay here's the thing so I
can it smells like you've been drinking
tonight so just what were you
drinking what were you doing at your
friend's house
um honestly we
had not a lot of drinks
okay but you had some is that
correct yeah okay
so I what I going have you if you could
just un buuck your seat belt okay
I'm walk your seat belt okay and goe and
step out of the car for
me could you head last check around the
corner 186 Detroit fem said that she
lives above the bar
said like someone's head was smashed
into a pi so that she didn't see
anything this is just what she thought
she heard so I played bball
okay
20 a copy 117
Lake I head that way as
well just a few minutes but she was pass
time okay come on go step out don't
don't turn this car on stop out of the
car
okay you're just F very well right now
so okay we're going to go over here
okay if it's all right with you I'm
going to run you through just a few
tests just to make sure okay is that all
right yeah okay just one second we have
to just cut the lights is there is there
anything wrong with your head any recent
head injuries do you wear glasses do you
wear contacts no let's move over this
okay yeah yeah let's go over here go
ahead and take your hands out of your
pockets for me just let's over this
way
I okay so face me what don't have you do
is just put your feet together arms at
your sides and then just keep your head
straight and then can you see my finger
what I need you to do is just focus on
it with your eyes your eyes only and do
not move your head doz that makes
sense my fer your eyes your
take okay that works better that way
just don't move your head Focus your
eyes with your eyes and your eyes up
just keep your
head only follow with your eyes okay got
it okay perfect
with your eyes only all right okay F
your finger my eyes with your eyes only
got it yep got it
okay
same thing okay
okay same
[Music]
thing I know it's a little right
now
now this
time again just with your
eyes
so next do is going to be the walk TR so
let going get you the starting position
okay all right so you don't have any
issues with any balance or your legs I
mean I don't know no no I'm asking you
the question you have any issues with
balance or anything not usually okay all
right so would you agree this is pretty
flat right here it's fine I I just got
to ask just make sure I want to make it
s for you I know I'm freezing I
understand all right okay what so have
you know arms sides so going you to put
your left foot on the line left just
imagine there's line there's imagine
there's a line going out put your left
foot on that line got it and put your
right foot in front got it heel the toe
I'm nothing just go the toe arms at your
side put that right foot front
put your right foot in front of your
left foot you on the top all
[Music]
right
okay
I I'm sorry I didn't see that mail was
sighted and released care of the
hospital
unitate
now what do body cams like this show you
that it's an unpredictable world right
and sometimes in that world you're going
to need a lawyer but finding the right
legal help is so important and let me
take a minute then to thank attorney Tom
and Associates for sponsoring this body
cam you see whether you were injured in
a car wreck or Refinery explosion or the
victim of Securities fraud or received a
notification that your information was
included in a data breach developed an
illness as a result of a bad drug or
toxic exposure and there are so many
other situations attorney Tom can help
you see what Tom and his team do so well
is they not only have the legal
knowledge of course but they have
genuine empathy for their clients and
having someone you can trust is
invaluable and by the way every call is
free it's private you'll be speaking
with a member of his team straight away
you won't pay a dime until you win which
just shows their commitment to your
success and they have an impressive
track record record in tough tough cases
and look if your case is not the best
fit for attorney Tom in his team don't
worry because they still may be able to
recommend you a lawyer because they have
a national network of attorneys they can
refer you to with attorney Tom and his
team you're not just hiring a lawyer
you're getting powerful allies who are
committed to Justice and your well-being
so if you've suffered an injury and you
need legal support click the attorney
tom.com bodycam link pinned in the
comments for a free consultation or 855
Tom wins I want to give you you know
Mage you can now I it like I said you
back to starting position left front of
the line right in front front he the to
arms at your sides he the to with make
sure that right
there right foot in front of it he to to
Arms Sid don't move go
ahead okay don't
move don't move that's I tell you to
start okay essentially you do is make
series of nice small st on the line turn
around and come back I'll demonstrate it
for you okay something like this so
you're going to go one two three I'm
only doing three you'll do nine and your
ninth step you leave your lead foot on
the line with your other foot make a
swall series of steps turn around okay
I'm not done get back in the position
starting position right yep left foot on
the line right foot heal the toe in
front remember got it I know heal heal
the toe I know you're not heal the toe
right now no I'm not ready to start no
but you have to stay in the starting
position until I tell you so real quick
we'll
readjust nope nope don't
start okay left foot on that line Sorry
left foot on the line
that's wrong way that's that reversed
left foot and then right foot in front
of it stay right there NOP right there
okay so I'll restart real quick so like
I
said I got to explain it to you okay no
I got it okay well I'm just going to
finish okay so you're do one two three
like I said all the way to nine then
leave your lead front the line so your
small steps turn around and then nine
back so again I'm only doing three
you'll do n now during the test I need
you to watch your feet while you're
walking count your steps out loud once
you start do not stop and count your
steps out loud for me okay you
ready freeing okay I understand like I
said keep your arms at your side all
right and you can start 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 9
okay got to do the turn
now okay and then nine heel the tow back
1 2 3 4 5 6
7 okay so we going to do one more test
okay got it it's going to be the one
legged stand test okay that's fine okay
so I'm going to put your feet together
arms at your sides now don't move until
I tell you to it's so
though you think that's going to affect
it right now no okay maybe I will be
blown over but okay we'll try our best
right now okay so arms at sides feet
together don't move until I tell you to
okay so I'm going to have you do is
you're going to pick up one leg it's
your choice either leg with your foot
approximately 6 in off the ground with
your foot parallel to the ground it's
going to with your leg straight it's
going to look something like this what
I'm going to have you do is I'm going to
have you look down at your foot and
you're going to count out loud 1001 1002
2 1003 and so on until I tell you to
stop okay okay you understand these
instructions y
okay wait wait are you ready oh my God
it's so like it's me okay are you ready
I don't
know this is kind of windy but all right
go okay go ahead 1001 1002 100 keep
that's your side 1004 make that foot
parall
just keep
going oh boy 1006 17 1008 1009 okay you
go and
stop okay so go and turn around for me
going put trans your back you're going
rest
for I'm that guy he just yes went over
that curb like a like really
bad like that I wasn't I was like yeah
that was crazy cuz he was watching us
instead of watching what he was doing
nice I
everything yes but based on what I just
observed you're you're intoxicated okay
so you're under arrest you can't you
can't obviously be intoxicated drive a
vehicle so we got a call earlier that
you were passed out in the line I came
somebody called probably an employee or
somebody in line and then you left do
you do you live
in why' you come back here he left and
then came and then came back because I
if you would have just came like left so
stupid you none of this would be
happening because I looked and you were
long gone you live where do you live I
live yeah so you were I checked all the
way down there and you were gone so I
don't know what made you home no who do
you live with do you live with somebody
yeah they can come pick you up at the
jail but we have to go through a bunch
of other paperwork before before you can
go home but you can go home okay okay
but it's going to take probably another
hour or so okay nothing that's going to
poke me in here or anything nothing I
nothing okay yeah like I said so you
went home and decided to come back yeah
to Taco Bell cuz I'm starving yeah well
I mean I know it's so stupid like I said
you would have just stayed home we
wouldn't be in this situation cuz I'm so
sorry we were out looking for you
earlier and there was uh you know you
weren't you were
gone here it's right there
yeah I don't be sorry to me I mean
what's this gum in here um what is that
I don't even know what that is that's
like a candy wrapper oh it's like a dove
wrapper who do you live with
um my boyfriend and yeah he he can come
get you sure I'm sorry
I you don't have any more pockets in
here no these are leggings so no no okay
no
pockets now we got to go do some more
paperwork at the station and then he can
come get you okay all
sorry sorry that's good is there
anything in your car that you might need
um like phone by chance there a phone in
there in the fanny pack
I'll okay I'll grab your phone I'll grab
your phone once we put you in the car
grab your phone all right all right
okay yeah I am I didn't even check I
just what's your name
Megan go take a just sit backward
yep she she definitely went home and
parked in her driveway cuz I
drove and did not see yep she must have
been home and then decided to come back
and look where she's at now and then
when they called me I was all the way
after 117 M I'm like okay
well I know you're hour day yeah well
when I came there was another car P next
I thought oh maybe like they're talking
and then that car went and I was like
nope they're not talking
yeah yeah this this comes back to North
so must be
different yeah she I mean she that's why
I asked her I'm like do you live she
obviously went home and cuz like I said
said I went all the way
down and she she was I mean she was
gone
[Music]
you
yes